this is a big story the Caitlyn Jenner
two-year anniversary special with Diane
Sawyer I am amazed that no one else is
talking about a few things in here that
that just stood just giant loud whistles
and sirens in this going off alarm bells
I think that there's a strong case we
made that the modern transgender
movement is is fascism that these are
true these are little [ __ ] fascists
and I mean it I mean that they are
fascist because you cannot ask questions
you will do as we say watching this
special really made me aware of just how
much of a divide there is between media
and not only the rest of the country but
the rest of the world
she writes after much deliberation I had
the final surgery in 2017 the surgery
was a success and I feel not only
wonderful but liberated so all of you
can stop staring but I wasn't less of a
woman the day before I had the surgery
than I was the day after I had the
surgery which begs the question why do
the surgery I mean I watched him what is
it me I was just as much of a woman who
shot her like the Joker from the back
before the surgery then why do it
because I felt I felt liberated how did
you feel liberated if you were already a
woman and she issues a kind of social
warning saying this is a topic only a
transgender person can bring up and the
rest of us should never ask how I would
make a suggestion to all people out
there don't ask the question it's not an
appropriate question to ask I guess
different Don't Ask Don't Tell it's
never appropriate to ask the question
how about your doctor how about your DMV
how about the fraternity clip fertility
clip how about when I go and purchase a
firearm they say is this the right
address
yes did you check the right sex box
along with a non Latino that seems a
little racist but yes the first question
a doctor has to ask especially when
we're dealing with healthcare right when
we're dealing with subsidizing other
people's healthcare it's never
appropriate to ask sometimes it's
appropriate some of us appropriate
sometimes it's appropriate for
identification sometimes it's
appropriate for concerned parents when
it comes to modesty or maybe concern
it's like listen listen listen I don't I
don't hate you but I think it's kind of
appropriate you're gonna be showering
with my daughter she issues a stern
warning you should never ask
and only transgenders can bring it up
isn't that social justice warrior ISM -
to a tee yeah they just assume we're all
on and if you're not honest because your
intolerance case-in-point like they want
you to act well yeah this is this is
sensible parity my kid at three said
everyone thinks I'm a girl and I'm not
and then I said however you feel is fine
and then Penelope said no I don't feel
like a boy mama I am a boy that's as
clear as it gets
I suppose there's three years old and
they act as though every and every one
sitting there crying like yes yes as
though people aren't watching this from
home going No
you're not buying that are you like they
want to act as though we're all sitting
there just saying oh of course I think
this kind of a parent more parents are
turning their children transgender I
think there are some people who
definitely have some kind of an
inclination where you're sitting and
they it's it's really hard to get them
off target but I think there are
probably more kids who say I want to be
a boy I mean this is the kid who just
wiped his boogers in the couch and
you're letting him make decisions
regarding his permanent biology it's
your job to keep your kids on the
straight and narrow until they're adults
but you when you veer off by the time
they're three because of some offhanded
statement it is I think it's borderline
child abuse and then they point to this
this California School Superintendent
which this is just great to me because
the super tolerant left don't realize
that they're not intolerant enough in
this special because they praise as
California superintendent for him
finding common ground his schools have
nearly 10,000 students a few years ago
after parents and teachers decided to
talk together the school now has some
gender-neutral bathrooms which he says
are freely used by all kids except
that's also hate speech that's not
enough there are states where they want
to force businesses to you can't have
gender-neutral bathrooms wait what yeah
there have been they say well we're
gonna open a gender-neutral bathroom you
can't that still hate speech we should
be allowed to use any bathroom we want
we've tried to find common ground with
the gender-neutral bathrooms it's not
been allowed it's not been accepted so
they Diane Sawyer to people at ABC don't
even realize this is the new frontier
for civil rights
they don't want unisex bed they don't
want gender-neutral bathrooms we even
ran into it at the intersectional
feminist Film Festival
completely just general need for bath
accessories and we actually consulted
with the trans community and they said
actually to protect feminine identifying
people and trans women they would prefer
to have feminine identified masculine
identified and then also with
gender-neutral restrooms so we made that
change okay so you have all three so
just sit over if you have bathrooms yeah
there here's something else that they
they brought up which i think is
important to touch on because the it
sort of it brings us into a bigger
discussion that is often misleading
let's watch this and here's an
interesting finding if you have one
identical twin who's transgender there
is a 39% probability the other will be
too signaling something is genetic or
signaling you're a parent when the one
twin says I won't be a boy you say fine
and the other says me too
seriously it doesn't take that into
account
it doesn't take parenting into account
point is if one twin at three says I'm a
boy and you accept it well of course the
other one's going to push the boundaries
here's something else that's really
important because this is served as the
foundation from the argument for a lot
of transgenders for decades I think the
original study was 7075 so whatever it's
called the the gender fluidity study by
dr. John money and this was one where he
raised twin boys he raised one as a boy
and he raised one as a girl and the idea
here if you go to the study they talk
about how they were raised differently
how they actually had different
different sexualities different
orientations how one clearly was born
this way and it was considered to be a
resounding success that this kind of
identified that there was something
different genetic with gender dysphoria
and this has been cited for a very long
time as a matter of fact if you search
transgender twins or if you search
gender fluid study the first several
pages that show up are all medical
journals that have published this and
have praised dr. money
the twin who transitioned was actually
suicidal at 13 years old what they don't
tell you and died of a drug overdose the
other twin the one who was a brother
committed suicide a year later at 38
years old and the guy who performed this
actually dr. money was not against he
made cases for pedophilia and molested
many of his patients to the point where
there are many child patients who didn't
want to return to him now this is not
new news it's only been newly brought to
light thanks to new media and this is
one of the most cited studies to
undergird the transgender argument when
in fact it proves the exact opposite it
said it's sad especially when we know
the suicide rate we know the suicide
rate is horrible with transgender people
and we know it doesn't get better after
the surgery and there are several
studies that show there's a Swedish
study the famous say there's also a
Canadian study if they're 18 to 19 times
more likely than the general population
to kill themselves so once they're
transgender
there's no going to the suicide rate is
still 40-something percent doesn't
matter what you do yeah so if you want
to save lives if your goal is just to
save lives and you want to be on the
happy trains it's about personal
happiness the fact is if you go down
that path you put that kid on the path
at three years old transgender you say
we're gonna go along with this 41
percent likelihood that Kitchen tries to
kill himself you've created that path
doesn't matter if you think they're
happier and they seem really unhappy at
3 or 4 years old doesn't matter if you
give them their first pump of estrogen
at 9 because they really really want it
once you go down that path they're 18
times more likely to kill themselves so
let's be less concerned about they say
in this special you know I don't want to
make it income but I don't want my baby
to kill themselves okay I don't think
your kid is going to kill themselves
because another parent doesn't want a
dong in their lady's bathroom your kid
is going to attempt suicide
statistically 19 times 18 times more
likelihood because you've allowed what
appears to be a very serious psychiatric
condition to go unchecked the endgame is
the same I was sitting there watching
this at home going they assume that
we're not laughing our ass off at
statements like this and tonight the
general dronov sent word they prefer to
stay private instead giving us a
statement
we love our father and have deep
admiration for her bravery though that's
just common language to everyone else
from cave people clobbering women with
clubs and dragging them back into their
hut dad has been he okay okay they're so
out of touch in New York and DC in LA
they don't even realize that people are
watching this laughing like we're and
that's the vast majority of the country
case in point there was this video honey
honey show me I can
[Music]
civics with metallic Aiki subtly basic
rights a motive most Americans are
watching this thinking that it is the
sideshow that it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you like this clip it's taken from
the full daily show available
exclusively at ladder with credit comm /
mug club that's for mug club members
because we can't be dependent here in
the Google YouTube overlords subscribe
there we have a daily show full hour
every day if you don't well there's no
saving you